so another question about Theory of
Everything But for intelligence do you
think there exists as you're exploring
this with xai creating this intelligence
system do you think there is a theory of
intelligence where you get to
understand what
like what is the i in AGI and what is
the i in um human intelligence there's
no I in team America oh wait there
is
oh it's going to be stuck in my head
now uh
yeah there's no me and
whatever uh in quantum mechanics oh
wait uh I mean is that part of the
process of discovering understanding the
universe is understanding
intelligence
yeah yeah I think we need to understand
intelligence understand Consciousness I
mean there I mean there are some sort of
fundamental questions of like what is
thought what is emotion yeah um is it
really just one atom bumping into
another atom it feels like something
more than
that uh so I I I I I think we're
probably missing some really big things
um like some really big things something
that'll be obvious in retrospect yes
like there's a giant like you put the
whole Consciousness emotion
well some people would call like a like
a soul you know religion is a soul um
like you feel like you're you right I
mean you don't feel like you're just a
collection of atoms but on what
dimension does thought exist what
dimension does do emotions exist we feel
them very
strongly um I suspect there's more to it
than atoms bump into
atoms and maybe AI can pave the path
through the discovery what whatever the
hell that thing is yeah what is
consciousness like what when you put the
atoms in a particular shape why are they
able to form thoughts and take actions
that and and
feelings and even if it is an illusion
why is this illusion so compelling yeah
like how why does this illusion
exist yeah on what plane does this the
solution exists yeah um and sometimes I
wonder
is you know either perhaps everything's
conscious or nothing is
conscious um one of the two I like the
former everything conscious just seems
more fun it do seem more more fun yes um
but we're composed of atoms and those
atoms are composed of quarks and leptons
and those quarks and leptons have been
around since the beginning of the
universe the beginning of the universe
right what what seems to be the
beginning of the universe